[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique pour un
débat consacré au gilet jaune hier la
participation a été moins forte au
niveau national pour ce 5e samedi
d'action mais hélas encore été
importante en franche-comté notamment à
dole et à besançon à besançon où des
heurts ont éclaté à la fin de la
manifestation
la manifestation proprement dite a donc
été suivi par plus de 12 cents personnes
ce mouvement d gilet jaune et il le
symptôme d'une crise démocratique
profonde
regardez cette image que dit ce gilet
jaune dans son dos je suis le peuple
demain démocratie directe votons nous
mêmes nos lois sans intermédiaire
corrompus pour en débattre trois invités
sur ce plateau tout d'abord se fie à
mais là elle est conseillère régionale
de bourgogne franche comté
elle est au rassemblement national face
à elle de nice au maire député du doubs
de la république en marche
et puis marie christine dalloz députée
les républicains du jura n'oubliez pas
sur twitter vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission
grâce au hashtag dit mme paul fc donc
quand vous voyez cette photo je suis le
peuple demain démocratie directe votons
nous mêmes nos lois sans intermédiaire
corrompus madame hamm à la quelle est
votre réaction
je vois ce que demande le peuple je
soutiens
ses revendications en fait de ce gilet
jaune s'est donné un peu plus de pouvoir
au peuple ce ce même peuple que je vais
vous vous êtes élue à la région vous
voudriez vous considérez du peuple ou
pas tout à fait tout à fait et je peux
je connais bien leur mal-être puisque
voilà moi aussi j'ai eu dix 10 mois ou
le disent mais je n'avais plus du tout
haut de pouvoir d'achat et ce peuple
aujourd'hui on est malheureusement donc
je reviens à la région ne représentait
ni écoutés marie christine dalloz quand
vous voyez ce gilet jaune qui dit ça
dans son dos vous dites quoi vous re
situons nous on est parti on est parti
d'une crise par rapport à des taxes sur
le carburant qui était insupportable
pour le budget des ménages
l'unanimité s'est faite les jets
régionaux des par son parti sur cette
revendication est dense
moi ça fait un an et demi que je dénonce
la trajectoire de la taxe carbone gelé
dénoncé en septembre 2010 est donc c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui qu'on avait compris
qui aura un problème si le prix du brut
augmentent et derrière maintenant que le
président de la république a annoncé
qu'il supprimait les taxes pour 2019
on voit bien fleurir d'autres
revendications et moi je peux comprendre
qu'il vient pouvoir d'achat je crois que
vraiment c'est un des mets là on est
passé à autre chose maintenant justement
j'ai ri mais le niveau des prélèvements
aujourd'hui est trop élevé en france on
le sait on l'a l'air tout en alerte
depuis des années il faut trouver une
solution mais derrière on est passé à
une crise démocratique je suis assez
d'accord je vais vous dire je suis
député du jura depuis depuis 11 ans
maintenant je me sens complètement le
peuple et les la circonscription que je
représente au jura les gens dans la rue
vivienne me voir quand je fais mes
courses ils viennent me voir j'ai des
rendez-vous dans mes permanences où je
rencontre avec leurs difficultés
je ne me sens pas éloigné du peuple
démissionnaire vous vous sentez le
peuple aussi coûté ge
j'ai connu des périodes pas facile
voilà jeté ouvrier chez peugeot pendant
quinze ans je travaillais à la chaîne
j'ai repris des études j'ai connu des
périodes une période de chômage assez
longue
je sais ce que c'est que la galère
voilà mais est ce qu'il faut faire la
preuve de sa en permanence on a été élu
on été choisi par nos concitoyens et je
crois que notre activité de tous les
jours montrent que nous restons pas
seulement eu des petites heures marche
ça vaut pour l'ensemble de mes collègues
j'ai ptet marie christine dalloz tout de
suite on reste très proche en réalité
des gens nos permanences sont ouvertes
aux rencontre régulièrement les gens le
samedi voire y compris le dimanche matin
a très souvent
voilà donc on a une vraie proximité par
contre ce qui est vrai c'est que on a
une crise démocratique c'est une réalité
mais qui ne date pas non plus de 18 mois
soyons soyons clairs y compris le
paradoxe de la situation c'est que
emmanuel macron a été élu sur la base
même de ce diagnostic ou emmanuel macron
y compris dans son livre dans son livre
révolution explique qu' une partie de la
société française ne sont plus
représentés par ces élus et qu'on vit là
une couleur il a peut-être fait le
diagnostic mais il n'a pas amené
apporter des remèdes à ben voilà mais
c'est là qu'on peut poursuivre
certainement le débat mais c'est quand
même le paradoxe président qui a été élu
sur un diagnostic qui aujourd'hui en
réalité se retourne contre lui il a fait
son thème de campagne
c'était le dégagisme rappelez-vous ni
droite ni gauche
la résultat des courses il a explosé les
partis politiques classiques il a
affaibli les syndicats depuis son
élection
et aujourd'hui quand il veut parler il
ya plus de corps intermédiaires
donc il a obligé de parler avec le
peuple c'est pas du tout son habitude
premièrement c'est pas dans sa culture
et puis c'est difficile de s'adresser à
une masse avec ses baraques avec les
attentes différents et avec des
revendications pas du tout homogène mais
on a vu aussi que vous chez les
républicains vous avez été g gêné aux
entournures laurent wauquiez à porter le
gilet jaune après la nuit et la voir
portée et on vous a senti quand même
dansé d'un pied sur l'autre
il n'y a pas que les républicains il n'y
a pas un parti politique aujourd'hui cap
a été regardée même la cgt
j'ai écouté attentivement l'autre soir
un débat sur le sujet
à la base la cgt ne veut absolument rien
à voir avec les jets les jaunes au
départ du mouvement
et puis au fil du temps c'est la base de
la cgt les médias moi je vous parle des
républicains et c'est la base de la cgt
qui impose de venir justement sur ce
mouvement sur les républicains
donc c'était une erreur de diagnostic
sur les républicains ce que ce qui est
parti de ce mouvement là à l'origine
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait l'historique
tout à l'heure à l'origine du mouvement
ont le dénonçait depuis longtemps les
républicains que cette taxe c'est sûr
taxe carbone qui n'allaient pas à la
transition écologique mais lequel au
budget de l'état était une ère va faire
parler hmad hammad mais là est ce que
vous avez beaucoup de militants du
rassemblement national sur les ronds
points
bien évidemment on se sent vraiment
concerné voilà les revendications vous y
êtes allé vous oui j'y suis allée oui
j'y suis allé je suis allé vers chez moi
celle à voujeaucourt voilà il ya
plusieurs ans puis il ya dans il ya eu
aussi dans les rues de montbéliard moi
je suis à côté de montbéliard donc
et est-ce que centenaire est ce qu'on a
le sentiment quand même que emmanuel
macron n'a pas de mandat
avant d'être président de la république
il a un peu hors seul vous avez vous les
députés in a beaucoup qui sont sans
expérience et justement est-ce que vous
ne payez pas au prix fort cette
inexpérience général du bie là-haut à
paris non mais je pense que c'est
évident qu'on a de ce point de vue une
une difficulté qui s'est corrigé
d'ailleurs un peu avec le temps mais le
simplement pour reprendre ce que disait
marie christine dalloz sur le dégage
isme c'est pas emmanuel macron qui a qui
a tué les autres les autres partis ils
sont tués tout seul à la fois le
programme de benoît hamon sur le revenu
universel qui coûtait au final 300
milliard
et puis on sait ce qui s'est passé avec
françois fillon donc en fait il ya un
espace qui s'est ouvert à l'idée qu'il
fallait reconstruire quelque chose qui
reprennent on pas le ni ni
mais qui reprennent et ce qui pouvait
être intelligent à droite et ce qui
pouvait être intelligent à gauche
alors on va se 6 10 là où il ya une
vraie difficulté est là où il ya une
vraie difficulté c'est que je pense que
le rythme de réduit des réformes a
largement pénalisé le débat c'est ça a
été je pense trop vite et surtout et
surtout on ne s'est pas appuyé sur les
corps intermédiaires et là je suis
d'accord avec marie christine dalloz
oui mais ça c'est pas depuis 18 mois
qu'ils ont disparu mais je pense que le
débat avec les organisations syndicales
le débat avec l'ensemble des des élus
les maires les conseillers
départementaux les conseils régionaux a
largement manqué au cours de ces
derniers de ces derniers mois mais je
pense conduire vers un long débat alors
on va regarder tout de suite une
question qui nous a été envoyé par
christian ou plutôt une remarque il dit
je n'ai pas confiance dans les
politiques ni le maire ni le député ni
les syndicats
madame hamm est là quand on voit le
front national puis maintenant le
rassemblement national qui est condamné
régulièrement que ce soit pour n 'a
citation à la haine raciale ou pour les
assistants parlementaires donc à
l'europe qui en fait c'est l'europe qui
paient des assistants parlementaires qui
faisaient pas leur travail et qu'ils
étaient des permanents aux partis
politiques
est ce que vous pensez pas que là tous
les partis politiques peuvent être mis
dans le même sac
ben si je pense que si on peut tous est
mis dans le même sac mais mais je pense
que nous sommes aussi un parti qui
sommes
on est vraiment proche proches de ceux
de ces gens de ce peuple
tout ce qu'ils demandent encore même
hier quand tu sens par les nomades même
même vous quand il les gens disent on a
plus confiance dans les partis
politiques vous mais c'est aussi le
vôtre dans ce nom que la main non non
vous avez dit oui tout à l'heure mais
oui non mais on n'a pas les mêmes
je pense que qu'au rassemblement
national on est beaucoup plus proche du
peuple
on est sonné moi je suis allé au las
tout à l'heure vous m'avez parlé des
ronds-points de ma part et de la rue j'y
suis allé j'ai pas vu de paris et proche
du peuple
oui tout à fait c'est le seul peuple
c'est cesser nos compatriotes avant les
autres c'est d'une autre avant les
ovocytes et les élus du rassemblement
sonel qui peuvent aller sur les ronds
points
moi je voudrais citer aussi les élus de
la france a soumises qui sont
régulièrement sur les ronds points
la particularité c'est ça vous avez tout
à l'heure évoqué laurent wauquiez et
j'expliquais que à la première au prg la
première manifestation au premier
rassemblement il ya vu beaucoup moins de
violence que le week end le deuxième but
kent que l'acte 2 mai au premier c'était
à taxes sur les carburants
et là il y avait une cohérence depuis on
a pris de la distance par rapport au
coût de 10
on a pris de la distance parce qu'on
s'est rendu compte que à la fois la
violence et l'ensemble des
révendications sortir de l'europe par
exemple moi c'est pas une revendication
que je peux porter demain c'est pas
possible c'est pas dans ma culture
mais la réalité aujourd'hui quand vous
interrogez un peu les gilet jaune
beaucoup beaucoup je dis pas tous mais
une partie celui qui je sais pas la
personne qui dit qu elle ni son maire ni
son député ni son conseiller
départemental mais son conseiller
régional la remise en cause de tous les
élus c'est une chose mais ça veut dire
qu'on change de constitution son rêve
lire justement va et venait alors donc
deux chiffres parce que ce manque de
confiance dans les politiques fait que
le taux d'abstentionnisme bat des
records ces dernières années un petit
rappel le chiffre de l'abstention à la
présidentielle de 2007 au premier tour
c'est 22% au deuxième tour 25 est
beaucoup plus fort encore aux
législatives c'est les dernières qui ont
vu donc de nice au maire et marie
christine dalo et lui c'est au premier
tour 51 % au 2e tour 57 % on va on va
voir tout de suite aucune question de
sophie qui s'adresse au gilet jaune qui
ne se sont pas déplacés justement pour
aller voter la dernière fois et qui dit
vous ne vous êtes pas déplacés pour
aller voter ya 18 mois maintenant aller
voter alors les causes donc de
l'absentéisme on l'a vu c'est
certainement le manque de confiance les
conséquences c'est peut-être la crise
des gilet jaune
on va écouter maintenant et
manuel macron le président semble avoir
entendu ce besoin de démocratie directe
voici ce qu'il a dit lundi soir je veux
que ce soit poser les questions qui
touchent à la représentation la
possibilité de voir les courants
d'opinion mieux entendue dans leur
diversité
une loi électorale plus juste la prise
en compte du vote blanc et même que
soient admis à participer aux débats des
citoyens n'appartenant pas à des parties
[Musique]
de nice au maire j chronométrie ça fait
quinze secondes 15 secondes sur une
intervention 13 minutes il aurait pas dû
pu y consacrer plus de temps pour il a
traité beaucoup de beaucoup de sujets là
il n'a pas traité aussi beaucoup de la
transition énergétique par exemple ça
lui a été reprochée je crois qu'il ya il
ya une décision qui a été prise qui est
particulièrement importante ces derniers
ces derniers jours c'est de repousser le
débat sur la réforme constitutionnelle
pourquoi parce qu'il ya le débat qui va
ce qu'il va s'engager partout sur le
terrain dont la fameuse consultation sur
trois mois la consultation sur trois
mois et donc la réforme que tu le débat
sur la réforme constitutionnelle viendra
après seulement pour tirer les leçons du
débat qu'on que l'on va conduire partout
sur le terrain les uns les unes et les
autres et je pense que ça c'est
extrêmement important et moi j'appelle
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens à
participer à ce débat là parce que dans
la réforme constitutionnelle la question
de la de la proportionnelle est à
l'ordre du jour alors peut-être pas un
niveau suffisant je crois que c'est dans
le projet réformiste et 15 4%
la question 15% des députés qui a le
sens des députées d'être élue elle a
pris compris une one députés et moins un
sénateur à l'échelle à l'échelle
nationale et la question du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne qui à mon avis
mérite d'être justement d'être
travaillés en or où on va on va regarder
la question de victor qui dit la vème
république est fini il faut passer à
autre chose maintenant madame hamm et là
est ce que vous êtes d'accord
la vème république s'est terminée autour
de la page on passe à autre chose
mais écoutez oui je pense que il faut
que redonner un peu la parole au peuple
aujourd'hui
et redonner un peu de pouvoir qu'on
puisse les écouter donc ce que disait
monsieur sa mère aussi qu'on va parler
aussi des référendum vous assistent
d'initiative citoyenne vous à inciter
vos militants vos sympathisants à
participer à cette consultation
nationale
ben oui toute façon oui oui j'insiste à
participer que qu'on entende leur voix
on parlait il ya deux minutes de
proportionnelle nous nos voix ne sont
pas entendus au regard des dernières
législatives
nous avons eu sept députés vont
aujourd'hui nous en aurons six et
pourtant nous avions 11 millions
d'électeurs donc c'est quand on va
écouter justement on va écouter
justement quelques réflexions de gilet
jaune sur ce besoin de davantage de
démocratie on les écoute tout de suite
été prié pour des lapins de trois
semaines voilà quarante ans maintenant
c'est le peuple qui bouge c'est pas ni
politique ni sa vie car c'est le peuple
qui serait heureux y a personne
aujourd'hui qui est capable de
représenter le peut le peut et on devra
avoir quand même des référendum
d'initiative populaire pourquoi c'est
tout décider là haut pour points déjà ce
qu'on veut c'est la proportionnelle
c'est quand même malheureux j'en ai pas
plus pour mélenchon que pour le pen
quand vous voyez que 40% des gens votent
pour un mouvement un autre ils ont 7 10
députés c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal c'est pas normal qu'ils ont ils
peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent ces gens
là il peut faire ce qu'ils veulent non
pas d'opposition
l'opposition ne vaut plus rien et les
mots
[Musique]
alors l'opposition est morte alors je
confirme qu'il est très l'opposition est
morte
non non notre position n'est pas morte
je suis une peut-être
voilà une preuve vivante qu'on est on
est dans l'opposition et on peut par
contre je confirme que il est très
difficile d'être dans le positif
opposition avec ce gouvernement
ça tient à la fois c'est pas votre
premier mandat de prouver que gérer j'ai
une comparaison autant dans le mandat
précédent on arrivait à avoir sur
certains amendements
un accord de principe du gouvernement
socialiste
là aujourd'hui rien absolument rien ne
passe il ya une fermeture hermétique de
la majorité au gouvernement vous fera
répondra et ré denis sommet mais vous la
constitution de la vème république à
vous y tenez vous voulez pas qu'on me
change à celle de 2 du général de gaulle
j'entends dire il faut plus de
proportionnelle
je sais pourquoi on est passé on sait
tous pourquoi on est passé à la vème
république
parce que la quatrième c'était la
république des partis
la république des partis faut se
rappeler de ça et que le général de
gaulle quand il a pris conscience de ça
c'était des arrangements entre partis
pour justement mais là sur 15% des
députés c'est pas les partis qui vont
alors dit tout il ya deux choses dans la
réforme constitutionnelle
il y avait 15 % de proportionnelle et
bien y avait il une pression d'un
certain nombre de députés
or le constat qu'on peut faire c'est que
la crise des gilets jaunes n est pas
parti de paris elle est partie des
territoires ruraux
c'est cela qui sont le plus en
souffrance par rapport au coût de la vie
il pas transport en commun fait part à
boro taxe carbone donc on est parti de
la ruralité
demain dans la réforme avec la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
députés
c'est pas en ville qu'on va supprimer
des députés madame nseries c'est dans
les territoires ruraux les territoires
ruraux ils sont calmes sur représentés
au sénat mène au nom ils sont pas sur
représentés attendez il ya une
représentation normale des territoires
ruraux aujourd'hui si demain au sénat
comme à l'assemblée on supprime des
parlementaires et bien la ruralité sera
sous représentés et la colère elle sera
encore plus grande
alors donc un système trop verrouillée
et l'opposition n'a pas la parole à
l'assemblée
mal alors que comme vous êtes encore
majoritaire je crois au sénat et puis
deuxièmement si à la proportionnelle en
fait il y aura une coupure avec les
territoires ruraux
ces deux points m et rapidement je serai
bien qu'on parle du du référendum très
bien donc je pense que cette majorité
elle a souffert d'un péché de jeunesse
et quand on est majoritaire à ce point
oui ben il ya parfois une attitude qui
peut être extrêmement méprisant points
oui je dirais pas ça mais au moins
oppressante un peu voilà est par contre
j'étais co rapporteur de la loi pacte je
sais que j'ai fait un travail très
collectif avec l'ensemble du député de
quelques de quelques orientations qu'il
soit donc c'est aussi possible de
travailler de cette manière mais je
retiens quand même une phrase de gérard
collomb quand il est parti là dit il
faut qu'on apprenne à être humble et ça
et ça je pense qu'il a bien fait nous
alerter ce jour là s'il étend la
proportionner sur la question de la de
la proportionnelle et des terrils je
pense qu'on ne peut pas continuer de
cette manière avec un scrutin uniquement
majoritaire où on a 30 ou 40% des
électeurs qui ne trouve pas une
représentation plus forte à l'assemblée
nationale donc il s'agit pas de retomber
dans les travers de la quatrième
république parce qu'on sait à quel point
ça pu être mortifère aussi pour la ville
l'état et au final pour la vie
démocratique mais d'un de d'instiller
une dose de provins de proportionnelle
significative pour permettre à
l'ensemble des courants de pensée qui
traversent notre société de pouvoir
présenter ce cas c'est bien ce que dit
emmanuel macron j'aimerais donc on parle
maintenant du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne le riz qu on a vu donc ce
petit sigle sur les manifestations ces
derniers jours donc c'est quoi c'est
qu'une proposition de loi obtenant cette
somme sept cent mille signatures de
citoyens donc puisse être devenir une
loi est de passer à l'assemblée
nationale est dedans
cette proposition de loi on a également
la possibilité de révoquer des élus est
ce qu'au front national vous êtes pour
ou contre ce type de référendum
bien évidemment qu'on est pour c'est ça
fait déjà de nombreuses annick marine le
pen l'a proposé sauf qu'on l'appelait le
référendum d'initiative populaire
mérite ça faisait un peu trop mortuaire
où est il ce sont que des mots et mais
le fond ça veut dire exactement la même
chose
c'est simplement donner aussi la parole
au peuple
redonnez aussi un peu de pouvoir
redonner un peu de pouvoir au peuple
je pense aussi que c'est aussi les sens
d'une démocratie voilà madame dalloz ce
qui m'interpelle c'est que j'ai j'ai été
très attentive aux revendications
multiples et variés un référendum pour
dire quoi alors j'ai entendu donc bons
d'émission de macron dix ans c'était le
slogan qui fédérait toulousain
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
sortie de l'europe le pouvoir d'achat
les retraités les jeunes les personnes
handicapées enfin il ya tellement de
choses comment mais tous ces messieurs
sur le système même d'un référendum sans
sans parler de ce qu'on mettrait dans le
référendum et sur la forme moi je trouve
que le référendum c'est l'expression
populaire si on regarde bien à côté de
nous on a des voisins en suisse qui sait
les votations qui font des votations sur
tous les sujets le système alors il ya
aussi de plus en plus beaucoup
d'abstention il se pose la question
comment ils font huer par exemple la
vocation l'une des dernières en suisse
c'était pour savoir s'il fallait
supprimer ou pas la redevance de la
télévision publique
alors bon bien sûr que cette idée n'est
pas passé donc les suisses continueront
de payer une redevance pour la
télévision publique
mais au moins ça a suscité un débat
national
elle aurait peut-être ça qui nous manque
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu
effectivement la grande scission qu'on
peut constater c'est et on le voit bien
les lois ne sont absolument pas d y a
pas de lieu de débat à par l'assemblée
et le sénat
et la réalité c'est que cette majorité
ça fait six mois qu'on entend dire
pédagogie on nous a pris un peu pour des
idiots ce gouvernement n'a pas arrêté
dire il faut faire de la pédagogie vous
savez celle l'union proposez quoi par
rapport au référendum vous proposer
trois pour consulter ou passez le tarif
le référendum est un bon moyen
démocratique pour que les gens
s'expriment
après ces quelques questions oppose dans
un référendum ce que souvent le sujet
les gens répondent pas à la question
mais à celui qui la pause on va demander
à denis sommer donc vous vous êtes pour
ou contre le référendum je sus pour ge
ce qui vient de se passer l'acte qui
s'est exprimé pendant pendant un mois
c'est vient de très loin je lui dit tout
à l'heure la crise démocratique et elle
n'est pas allée très loin on sait pas où
ça va nous emmener un oui absolument
mais on sait qu'on a besoin de redonner
la parole à nos concitoyens sur des
sujets qui les intéressent sur de quelle
manière le faire aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas capable de le dire c'est pour ça
qu'il faut le débat pendant pendant ces
trois mois il y aura la révocation des
élus par exemple en cours de mandat ah
ben ça peut il peut arriver que dans
certaines conditions
ce soit quelque chose de possible on
avait eu le débat sur appel ou bon
moment de la campagne électorale comme
ségolène royal était était candidate à
la présidentielle
ouais absolument et à l'époque ségolène
royal avait été largement raillé pour
ses propositions et notamment sur la
question de la participation citoyenne
et où on se rend compte que de ce point
de vue il avait fait un très bon
diagnostic et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
faut maintenant il faut y répondre
voilà donc on a trois mois pour
construire il faut le faire je suis
favorable à ce genre de deux
consultations donc aux références la
mise en moyenne juste une remarque quand
même quand on utilise très peu le
référendum au bout du compte vous avez
raison de rappeler que très souvent les
nos concitoyens ne répondent pas en fait
à la question posée mais s'exprime
général de gaulle est parti c'est là un
référendum perdu si on installe le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne comme
étant une pratique normale
je pense qu'on reviendra aussi à à des
citoyens d'une des concitoyens qui vont
se mobiliser ce sujet ce qui les
intéresse et qui apprécieront pouvoir
donner j'ai reçu une question pourquoi
ne pas consulter des citoyens pour des
grosses dépenses de la nation comme par
exemple paris 2024 pour les jeux
olympiques madame hamm et là vous en
pensez quoi il faudrait consulter les
citoyens sur une décision comme ça je
pense que de toute façon on peut
demander donc aux citoyens oui un peu
surfait sur tout mais légers aux plages
des légers os que ça ça quand même un
impact voilà m'aimait pas c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment le jeu trouve pas que
ce soit vraiment le sujet comme comme ce
qu'il ya de vraiment plus profond
aujourd'hui avec avec les gilles et jo
on ne sait pas c'est pas des lois
madame d'année proposé à monsieur mais
gilet jaune
les jeux olympiques les jeux olympiques
c'est c'est le l'image de la france donc
si la france est exclue des jeux
olympiques si si demain il ya un
référendum sur ce sujet là et qu on
exclut la france des jo en termes de
vitrine
je pense que ça serait fondamentalement
dommage mais ça sera encore le choix du
peuple et la révocation des élus vous
pensez que ces blancs et des juges
moi je croyais à démarrer tout de suite
non mais des élus coupables
non mais la démocratie et l'est elle a
quelque chose elle repose sur un système
démocratique
voilà les élections des gens élus après
il ya un système médiatique qui est là
il ya des questions à se poser sur les
médias parce qu'en matière d'information
de relais non non non je sais c'est pas
vous que je vais faire un procès mais il
ya une question à se poser sur le relais
des médias comment ils ont interprété et
quinze premiers jours ils ont pas vu le
problème des gilet jaune et médias
nationaux les médias nationaux personne
n'avait vu je pense qu'on a mais pas les
1 6 3 en région a été on avait alerté
longtemps pendant quinze jours j'ai
prêché dans le désert à l'assemblée
nationale je me vois un jour je me
souviens une nuit d'hier à monsieur
darmanin presque un véhicule sur deux
que je croise dans le jura dans le haut
jura ont un gilet jaune derrière le pare
brise
il a éclaté de rire jeudi vous pouvez
rire la réalité c'est celle ci et il
reste très peu de seconde
est-ce que là emmanuel macron a commencé
son mandat à 18 mois seulement
il est déjà dans une situation très
difficile vous voyez comment les trois
ans et demi qui reste je pense que les
trois ans et demi qui restent peuvent
très bien se passer à condition qu'on
tire les leçons de ce qui s'est passé
juste un mot quand même a dénoncé vont
quand même de gilets jaunes c'est
l'utilisation massive du numéro
oui mais je parlais de trial yves que
j'ai lu que passionnante d'un livre de
victor hernandez qui palliait mocratie
actuellement c'est vraiment très très
intéressant bon ça ça mériterait une
émission là les réseaux sociaux merci
mesdames merci monsieur d'art participer
à cette émission
bonne fin de journée à vous tous bon
dimanche après midi
on en reparlera des réseaux sociaux
promis juré merci beaucoup au revoir
[Musique]